[Música]
bienvenidos a este programa especial
sobre la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en costa rica
35 millones de personas estaban llamadas
a las urnas para elegir al sucesor del
presidente carlos alvarado el ex
presidente josé maría figueres del
tradicional partido liberación nacional
y el exministro de hacienda rodrigo
chávez de progreso social democrático
eran los aspirantes a ocupar el palacio
presidencial costarricense desde el 8 de
mayo hasta el
2026 sin embargo tras un veloz conteo
que ya supera el 93% chaves ya es
considerado el presidente electo con un
57,2 por ciento de los votos frente a un
42 7% del ex jefe de estado figueres a
esta hora conectamos con cindy y regidor
ella es corresponsal de france 24 en san
jose
cindy cuéntenos cómo se desarrolló esta
jornada
la jornada fue bastante tranquila hubo
poca presencia de votantes durante la
mañana y ahora que sabemos que el
abstencionismo subió de 40 en la primera
ronda a 42 por ciento en esta segunda
ronda quiere decir que esa poca
presencia de la ciudadanía también se
mantuvo hasta la tarde hasta las 18
horas cuando cerraron las juntas
receptoras de votos se trata de el
abstencionismo más alto de la historia
costarricense al menos desde
1948 y ya con el tercer corte con casi
el 90% de los resultados s
abstencionismo continúa subiendo hasta
un
42.7 por ciento
pero además de eso fue una jornada
bastante tranquila no hubo ningún tipo
de anomalías serias que dieran a
preocuparse a la población ni tampoco a
los magistrados del tribunal suprema
electoral sevilla conocemos estos datos
de participación que usted nos estaba
mencionando y quiero hacer una
corrección una aclaración y es que
chávez logró un 52 8% de los votos
frente a un 47 11% del ex jefe de estado
figueres hubo una denuncia justamente
que involucró a uno de los dirigentes
del partido de chávez que nos puede
decir al respecto
sí bueno la denuncia que hubo ayer por
la noche y que se conoció más detalles
hoy por la tarde era acerca de un
mensaje de texto que fue enviado de
manera masiva a los fiscales en las
mesas en todo el país en donde esta
persona un simpatizante del partido de
la 'u' el presidente electo ahora
rodrigo chávez advertía que habían
sanciones penales por cualquier tipo de
irregularidades o de delitos electorales
en las mesas eso fue calificado como un
mensaje intimidatorio por parte de los
magistrados del tribunal supremo
electoral y dijeron que estaban
analizando el caso con los abogados él
es el simpatizante de chávez dijo que él
mandó ese mensaje como un recordatorio
de lo que dice la ley electoral veremos
más adelante si eso implica algún tipo
de delito al respecto sin ti pues muchas
gracias por esta ampliación en unos
momentos volvemos con usted para seguir
comentando estos comicios y justamente
para analizarlos y al presidente electo
nos acompañan aquí en el estudio manuel
gonzález magíster en ciencia política de
la universidad de salamanca y vía skype
larisa al varios politóloga e
investigadora alejandro molina ramírez
politólogo y analista del observatorio
de la política nacional de la
universidad de costa rica a los tres les
doy la bienvenida
rodrigo chávez tiene una clara ventaja
en este conteo un candidato que no está
exento de polémica exministro de
hacienda y también ex funcionario del
banco mundial asegura que luchará contra
la corrupción y hasta hace pocos días
lograba una ligera ventaja en la
intención de voto que hoy se confirma
alva santana nos cuenta más de su
trayectoria
economista de profesión y natural del
distrito del carmen en costa rica
rodrigo chávez obtuvo un doctorado
económico en la universidad de ohio lo
que le abrió las puertas al banco
mundial donde trabajó durante más de 25
años
es económica como la que podía
en 2019 el político renunció a su cargo
y volvió a costa rica comenzó su carrera
política al ser fichado para ocupar el
ministerio de hacienda puesto que
desempeñó durante 184 días y del que
también terminó renunciando no fue hasta
2021 cuando anunció que se unía al
partido social democrático desde donde
ha defendido políticas conservadoras con
un discurso nacionalista y a favor de la
recuperación económica del país a través
de pactos con organismos como el egm el
actual acuerdo negociado pueden
mejorarse de acuerdo a los intereses del
país y que yo estoy muy anuente
renegociarlo con el compromiso de que no
incluirá más impuestos en su corta
trayectoria política chávez ya se ha
visto envuelto en varias polémicas el
mismo año que abandonó el banco mundial
este lo sancionó por acoso sexual a dos
de sus trabajadoras entre 2008 y 2013 y
recientemente el periódico wall street
journal publicó que chávez también
habría acosado a mujeres en indonesia
entre 2 18 y 2019 acusaciones que
siempre ha negado
periodista quien tardó dos semanas para
escribir la nota afirma que hubo una
conducta inapropiada necesidad de
indolencia y sabes como sustenta esa
temeraria afirmación con gente
familiarizada con el político muy
popular entre los costarricenses también
ha sido señalado por financiar su
campaña con cuentas bancarias no
declaradas
no puedes envuelto en un asunto
sumamente complicado estas denuncias de
acoso sexual en las que mujeres
afirmaron que intentó besar a empleadas
de menor rango y sus comentarios
sexuales sobre su apariencia y realizó
reiteradas invitaciones no deseadas
habitaciones de hotel y cenas empiezo
preguntándole señor gonzález qué mensaje
envía que una persona con este historial
logre los votos necesarios para ser
presidente de un país como costa rica
donde también hay un antecedente con el
ex mandatario oscar arias sánchez que
fue acusado en 2019 también de agresión
sexual o conducta inapropiada por al
menos nueve mujeres en uno de los casos
que fue de los más emblemáticos del
movimiento me tuve en américa latina'
bueno básicamente envía dos mensajes muy
negativos en primer lugar que la
justicia no está realizando su trabajo
es decir no está sancionando y no está
generando efectivamente esa sanción no
está digamos en el castigo frente a los
candidatos y sobre todo inhabilitándolos
de ubicarse en posiciones de poder y en
segundo lugar que américa latina'
desafortunadamente siguen una ola de
machismo sigue digamos tener una cultura
en donde no se tiene presente es digamos
esa consideración frente a las mujeres y
sobre todo generando sus espacios donde
las mujeres se sientan seguras sobre
todo en posiciones de poder bueno y en
este momento le doy la bienvenida ya se
lo había dado pero le reitero la
bienvenida a larisa álvarez quiero
hacerle esta misma pregunta y decirle no
sé esto no podría demostrar de alguna
manera que se está minimizando el
impacto de un delito tan grave o de una
conducta tan grave como es lo que se ha
denunciado contra el ahora presidente
electo
y si más gracias por el índico
nuestra imagen
en los 12 meses a sociedad sumamente mal
que intenta este intentar
con las demandas de las mujeres que
éstas a pasar a segundo plano
hemos visto que desde que salió la
denuncia varios colectivos de éstas han
intentado posicionar el tema es tentar a
una cancelación de poderes de chávez sin
embargo es perfecto entonces vemos por
ejemplo que por más intentos desde los
movimientos feministas desde los
movimientos de las mujeres inclusiones
de los mismos partidos políticos y desde
la prensa a intentar es posicionar este
tema intenta posicionar la importante
sistema no se ha logrado entonces vemos
que la sociedad a veces tira siente una
sociedad machista que también se expresa
en su voz expresa también en que le
restó importancia a este medio por
ejemplo vemos que la encuesta de desviar
la penúltima encuesta de cid
cuando se pregunta respecto a la demanda
de modric mucha basura cosas en
importancia ha tenido para definir en
voto en los electores en un gran
porcentaje ha aclarado que no que esto
no tuvo gran importancia
sin embargo cuando esta misma pregunta
se le hizo a los electores estén en caso
de josé maría figueres que tanta
importancia tuvo los casos de corrupción
acá la respuesta dio y la se ha definido
que mucha importancia le dio el
electorado familiares por ejemplo en en
su caso de producción al no votar por
ese entonces vemos que los
costarricenses tienen ciertas demandas
que son más importantes que otras
entonces también vemos cómo está
colocación verdad de unas demandas
prioritarias no demandas no prioritarias
bueno ahora pasó a hablar con alejandro
molina también le doy la bienvenida y le
preguntó por este mismo tema porque
digamos que uno de los puntos
importantes y que hizo muy visible
hachado es en un momento donde no era
tan relevante fue el apoyo de la
periodista pilar cisneros cómo se
interpreta que pilar cisneros que es una
persona con una reconocida carrera en el
país le de este apoyo creador de hecho
asumir uno de los cargos en el
parlamento
claro que la figura de doña pilar
cisneros ha sido fundamental para la
campaña del partido progreso social
democrático y su candidato y ahora
presidente electo rodrigo de chávez
debido a que en el observatorio de la
política nacional hemos dado seguimiento
a un fenómeno que hemos denominado la
personalización de la política en costa
rica en los partidos políticos hace
muchos años han venido abandonando
aspectos más ideológicos más
programáticos y existen más bien una
confluencia entre los partidos políticos
entre sí
alrededor de un consenso sobre el modelo
de desarrollo el cual aceptan
acríticamente y
de manera conjunta los intereses
favorecidos y hegemónicos el producto de
ese modelo de desarrollo entonces en un
marco en el cual los partidos políticos
ya no son aquellas maquinarias que no
solamente se encargaban de los procesos
electorales sino que también se
encargaban de la formación política y de
ser la expresión electoral
de determinada forma de pensar no solo
la política sino de ver el mundo lo que
ha tomado su lugar son los personalismos
y los que llamamos popularmente los
outsiders los liderazgos carismáticos de
alguna manera entonces el liderazgo o el
personalismo que tiene una periodista
que se ha ganado un prestigio a lo largo
de los años en costa rica precisamente
por su denuncia de los actores políticos
los gobiernos de turno los
representantes en puestos de elección
popular básicamente ha sido una figura
es sumamente relevante no solamente para
dar a conocer al candidato rodrigo
chávez sino también para en determinado
momento inclinar la balanza a favor de
su candidatura en la papeleta
presidencial de primera ronda habían
muchísimos candidatos con un perfil
similar el redondo griego si hablamos de
economistas habían varios economistas en
la papeleta candidatos beligerantes en
contra de la corrupción habían varios
también en la papeleta sin embargo una
hipótesis que parece ganar muchísima
fuerza es que el factor distintivo de
rodrigo chávez tanto en primera ronda
como en segunda ronda fue el tremendo
impulso que le dio una periodista que
ahora es diputada electa por la
provincia de san josé que es
precisamente el caso de doña pilar
cisneros bueno y ahora vuelvo con manuel
y le pregunto
tenemos que hablar que a pesar de esta
polémica y a pesar de ser un tema
sumamente complicado pues rodrigo chávez
ya es presidente electo y va a ocupar el
palacio presidencial de costa rica-
cuáles son las principales fortalezas de
chaves podemos hablar como ya lo estaba
mencionando alejandro un poco de su
imagen que busca romper con el llamado
establishment así es digamos que la
presencia de un outsider en el palacio
de gobierno en san josé pues de alguna
forma refleja un cambio en la política
costarricense recordemos que costa rica
siempre ha estado digamos dominado por
dos partidos principales el partido
liberacionista y el partido
socialcristiano en ese sentido es uno
aire en la política pero refleja también
la isaf acción de los costarricenses
frente a la democracia
allí asoman más más riesgos que los
beneficios en primer lugar porque chávez
no cuenta con la mayoría en el
parlamento tendría que hacer muchos
esfuerzos para lograr eso digamos esas
negociaciones y concitar al final de
cuentas una coalición que le permita
gobernar y en segunda medida siempre
chávez desde la campaña electoral
siempre propuso generar una serie de
cambios en las instituciones
democráticas siempre atacó el poder
judicial atacó las instituciones
democráticas y eso no es un buen mensaje
para una democracia modelo en américa
latina como es la costarricense entonces
creo yo que asuma mucho más los riesgos
que los beneficios de que haya llegado
chávez al palacio nacionalizándose bueno
vuelvo con larisa y justamente le
pregunto esto que ya estábamos que ya
está mencionando manuel y es que el
movimiento progreso social democrático
sólo tiene diez sillas dentro del
congreso como se ve el panorama de
gobernabilidad en el país
claro es que hay un detalle en el
congreso por ejemplo para una votación
simple se ocuparían 29 diputados
teniendo en cuenta que él provee el
partido progresó socialdemócrata este
rodrigo chávez sólo cuenta un día
diputado se ve en la obligación máxima
en negociaciones y acuerdos tienen
presidente no logra ser acuerdos y
negociaciones para este período no no va
a poder gestionar un buen gobierno ahora
bien hay un punto importante y es que la
legislación sobre periodos
extraordinarios y ordinarios la
estabilidad legislativa hace poco tuvo
un cambio constitucional y es que se le
otorga al poder ejecutivo este la
posibilidad de plantear por proyectos de
ley en los primeros tres meses de
gobierno esto es una medida
completamente nueva nunca aplicado costa
rica es una nueva reforma entonces vamos
a ver cómo puede el poder ejecutivo
rodrigo chávez aprovechar esta nueva
reforma y sus diputados aprovecharla
para gestionar nuevos acuerdos y nuevas
negociaciones de la asamblea legislativa
ahora bien también tiene un detalle muy
importante y es que para
para negociaciones con poco en mayoría
calificada es decir 38 diputados todavía
ocuparía hacer negociaciones más grandes
estas mayorías calificadas se ocupan
para proyectos de ley que sean
constitucionales porque sean de un gran
impacto para el país entonces vemos el
rodrigo chávez también a la hora de
empezar se ve presionado por esta
necesidad urgente de realizar
negociaciones y acuerdos con los demás
partidos políticos y con los demás
actores nacionales también y esto
también quiere decir un problema como
decía manuel en términos de gobernanza
ya que rodrigo chaves durante su campaña
electoral se ha caracterizado por tener
estos conflictos con ciertos sectores ha
tenido conflictos con el poder judicial
ha tenido los conflictos con la prensa
ha tenido conflictos con los movimientos
por ejemplo de mujeres este entonces
también ha tenido conflictos con los
movimientos ambientalistas por sus
propuestas entonces también vemos que
está iniciando con con el día equivocado
por así decirlo está iniciando con
conflictos con actores que necesitan
negociar y con los que necesitan
realizar acuerdos políticos
en estos momentos vamos a ver una
actualización de los resultados que ya
entrega el tribunal de elecciones y es
que con el 95
24 por ciento de los votos escrutados
ya rodrigo chávez logra un 52,8 por
ciento mientras que figueres logra un
47,12 por ciento de los apoyos
tenemos que decir en estos momentos que
el ex presidente josé maría figueres ya
reconoció su derrota en estas elecciones
lo que hace aún más oficial que ya
rodrigo chávez es el presidente electo y
a partir de mayo llegará al palacio
presidencial algo que también vale la
pena analizar es el abstencionismo que
hoy fue una cifra récord de más del 42
por ciento y que el pasado 6 de febrero
superó el 40 por ciento en esa primera
vuelta había 25 candidatos en contienda
lo que podría dar a entender que había
un abanico de opciones pero de alguna
manera los costarricenses no se sentían
representados le pregunto a alejandro
cómo se interpreta esta tendencia que se
confirma hoy
el tema del abstencionismo es algo que
es manifestación muy clara de lo que en
el observatorio de política nacional y
en la universidad de costa rica en
espacios académicos como el nuestro
hemos denominado crisis de
representación o crisis de los del
sistema de partidos políticos
costarricenses
en ese sentido la baja participación
refleja también este descontento con la
política tradicional y con el sistema
político en general lo cual sí tiene
causas de más profunda y de más larga
data que este propio proceso electoral
en ese sentido hay que resaltar que el
más interesado en que el abstencionismo
bajara era precisamente el ahora
presidente electo rodrigo chávez ya que
en costa rica es necesario aclarar que
por ejemplo las elecciones municipales
se realizan de manera separada de las
elecciones presidenciales y las
elecciones legislativas se realizan en
dos años después de las elecciones
presidenciales y son elecciones con una
muy baja participación entonces los
partidos políticos institucionalizado sí
que tienen una base electoral
consolidada como lo es en este caso el
partido liberación nacional
tiene más facilidades para que
precisamente hacerse con la victoria en
estas elecciones con muy baja
participación entonces es algo que hemos
señalado desde la universidad de costa
rica es que si las elecciones
presidenciales también se municipalicen
por utilizar una metáfora pues
evidentemente son los partidos
tradicionales los que parten con cierta
ventaja de cara a unos resultados
electorales
entonces el hecho de que en esta segunda
ronda la el abstencionismo no haya
crecido sustancialmente en comparación
con la primera ronda a pesar de que ya
la primera era un índice de
abstencionismo elevado en comparación
con procesos electorales anteriores sí
pues se puede interpretar que al acudir
una proporción similar del electorado a
las urnas pues esto benefició
eventualmente al ahora presidente electo
rodrigo de chávez existe un dicho en
costa rica es muy popular que dice que a
mayor abstención más fácil que gane
liberación precisamente porque con su
sola militancia el partido liberación
nacional tiene muchas posibilidades de
hacerse con la victoria en procesos
electorales con baja participación como
estoy mencionando entonces el hecho de
que el índice de abstencionismo haya
sido similar que en primera ronda y no
me más bien no se haya disparado pues
puede interpretarse que en esta ocasión
fue favorable para el partido progreso
social democrático y rodrigo chávez
bueno ahora hablemos del país que recibe
el próximo jefe de estado la economía
costarricense depende principalmente del
turismo y se vio fuertemente golpeada
por la pandemia en 2020 sin embargo en
2021 las cifras oficiales mostraron un
crecimiento del 76 por ciento pese a ese
indicador positivo costa rica es un país
de 5.24 millones de habitantes donde la
pobreza es del 23% y la tasa del
desempleo del 13,68 por ciento manuel le
pregunto cuál es el panorama actual de
costa rica- bueno costa rica no
atraviesa una buena situación económica
recordemos que la pandemia magnífico los
las brechas de desigualdad magnífico de
la pobreza y sobre todo el desempleo si
en el último tramo del gobierno del
presidente álvaro que ya deja su digamos
supuesto logro hacer una reducción
sensible de algunos este de estos
problemas lo que vemos es que costa rica
todavía afronta problemas estructurales
problemas relacionados con el turismo
problemas relacionados un poco con la
dualidad de la empresa es decir la el
trabajo informal y el trabajo formal y
en ese sentido lo que va a recibir el
nuevo gobierno es una serie digamos de
problemas o déficits fiscales sobre todo
relacionado con el fondo monetario
internacional entonces allí va a ser muy
importante los acuerdos que logra hacer
este presidente
sobre todo porque principalmente dos de
los grandes problemas que afronta costa
rica- los mismos ciudadanos lo han dicho
en las encuestas son el desempleo y de
alguna forma también lo que tiene que
ver con la desigualdad entonces de
alguna forma eso van a ser los dos
puntos que tiene que atacar este
gobierno que entra digamos en digamos en
esto digamos en estas elecciones bueno
ahora pasó a hablar con larisa y le
pregunto también un poco por este tema
económico porque costa rica tiene un
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional para recibir un crédito de
1.778 millones de dólares y tiene una
deuda pública de unos 42 más de 42 mil
400 millones de dólares como recibe el
nuevo presidente esta problemática si lo
podemos ver
problemático de alguna manera
no claro como nos decía manuel es el
nuevo presidente está tomando con saber
que una situación económica muy delicada
en una situación económica que el país
necesariamente se ve una posición que
ocupa hacer un acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional para este
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional se pudo pusieron en su
momento una serie de leyes este que
necesitaban su aprobación en la asamblea
legislativa ya vemos que la semana
pasada se aprobó una de las más
importantes espera reforma el empleo
público sin embargo todavía siguen
ciertas cuestiones o ciertas leyes y
proyectos que son necesarios su
aprobación para que en fondo continúe
con los desembolsos está sigue en bahía
en la asamblea legislativa entonces
también en nuevo presidente ocupa el
apoyo de la asamblea legislativa de los
demás partidos políticos que ocupa
necesariamente realizar negociaciones y
acuerdos esto con los demás partidos
políticos en dentro de su evento de la
bandera y y también en este el del poder
ejecutivo lograr gestionar verdad esta
gobernanza de partidos políticos y entre
apoyos que logren este sacar acosta
ubica esta crisis económica
bueno y termino esta ronda de la misma
pregunta hablando con alejandro porque
las estimaciones oficiales dicen que
este año costa rica va a cerrar con un
alza de 39 % que tanto puede afectar
este crecimiento
justamente estos indicadores graves de
los que estamos hablando como son la
desigualdad la pobreza y el desempleo
si en relación con esta situación
socioeconómica en la que el próximo
presidente en este caso el señor rodrigo
chávez va a recibir el país si tiene
mucha relación con lo que mencionaba
manuel en el estudio el problemas
relacionados con la desigualdad y
problemas relacionados con el desempleo
y también con el costo de la vida en ese
sentido por ejemplo cuando se en 2020 se
anunciaron las medidas tentativas con
las cuales el gobierno de la república
iba a intentar demostrar al fondo
monetario internacional- su capacidad de
pago para acceder a ese empréstito que
están mencionando que se desató uno de
los ciclos de protesta más prolongados
de la de la historia reciente del país
de la última década
ya que por qué
ha anunciado previamente por una de las
huelgas también más extensas en el 2018
precisamente por una reforma fiscal
anunciada por el gobierno de la
república y discutida en la asamblea
legislativa entonces costa rica si tiene
una situación socioeconómica sumamente
deteriorada de cara a este próximo
gobierno los problemas en el sistema de
acumulación producción y distribución de
la riqueza ha sido uno de los problemas
más críticos y cuya deuda de solucionar
se mantiene pendiente tanto por parte de
los partidos políticos como del sistema
en general las instituciones políticas
en costa rica han sido insuficientes
para solventar una serie de problemas
que la población costarricense reclama
como de urgente solución y los problemas
relacionados con el deterioro en la
situación socioeconómica del país
son uno de ellos los problemas en la
crisis de representación que mencionaba
anteriormente también tienen relación
con estas crisis el abandono al diálogo
social que durante estos cuatro años ha
sido particularmente marcado a pesar de
que vivimos una de las administraciones
más conflictivas a nivel por ejemplo el
ciclo de protestas dentro de la historia
reciente del país entonces
el hecho de que acumulamos estos
problemas irresueltos en la acumulación
y distribución de la riqueza pues es un
tema que que será de urgente atención
por parte del próximo gobierno y el
perfil de don rodrigo chávez pues puede
interpretarse que un economista
tecnócrata del banco mundial de varias
décadas pues un sector del electorado
costarricense
interpreta que es el adecuado para
hacerle frente a estas problemáticas
bueno pues en un poco menos de unos ocho
minutos estamos esperando el
pronunciamiento de rodrigo chávez de
presidente electo sería nueve de la
noche de san jose 10 de la noche hora de
bogotá y un poco en línea con la
pregunta anterior le pregunto manuel
cuáles son los principales retos para el
nuevo mandatario pero sobre todo cuál
sería su desafío más urgente su desafío
más urgente es renegociar el acuerdo con
el fondo monetario internacional de
alguna forma la cuestión relacionada a
la economía a la desigualdad son
problemas urgentes son problemas que han
generado protestas sociales como bien
son a mis colegas en el panel y al final
de cuentas todo va a pasar incluso por
la negociación política es decir un
presidente con minoría legislativa va a
tener muchos problemas a la hora de
concitar esos apoyos y sobre todo de
sacar adelante ese paquete de reformas
económicas que necesita urgentemente
costa rica pero yo diría que el
principal y el primero de todos de los
retos de chávez va a ser al final de
cuentas solucionar la problemática
económica
larisa vuelvo con usted y le pregunto
esto mismo cuál sería el desafío más
urgente para el nuevo presidente de
costa rica
pero acá concuerdo con manuel realmente
el desafío más urgente para el país con
la reforma económica que necesita
entonces para eso es necesario es volver
a negociar el acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional y asimismo otro
reto que iniciamos desde el observatorio
la política nacional es cómo lograr
calmar las aguas -este cómo lograr
generar los acuerdos y las negociaciones
necesarias en los temas el país este a
destacaban las encuestas que son sus
principales preocupaciones pero también
calmar las aguas y realizar acuerdos y
negociaciones este con los sectores con
los que han tenido discrepancias el
alrededor de la campaña política vemos
que en cantidad todo chávez ha sido muy
polémico este no sólo por sus
acusaciones de acoso sexual sino también
porque ha tenido problemas esté con la
prensa ha tenido problemas con el sector
salud ha tenido problemas con el sector
de poder judicial todos estos sectores
éste necesitan una reunificación
entonces me parece que también uno de
los problemas más complicados para
chávez este desde el término social y
también desde como lo decía alejandro
desde que el país viene saliendo un
ciclo protestas y ampliados es que se
necesita en este país generar esa
cohesión social generar esa unidad y
para salir adelante
hablo con alejandro ahora porque sabemos
que costa rica es reconocida como la
democracia más estable de américa
latina' qué grado de confianza hay en
las instituciones en esta nación y cuál
sería la relación porque ya usted lo
estaba mencionando antes que hay una
especie de situación problemática entre
entre chaves o lo ha habido hasta el
momento varias críticas a las
instituciones
y el prestigio o la valoración que hace
la población costarricense de las
instituciones políticas varía según la
institución de la que estemos hablando
particularmente
vemos que por ejemplo instituciones que
han sido garantes de la estabilidad y la
paz social en costa rica como lo puede
ser la caja costarricense del seguro
social que es básicamente nuestro
sistema de salud pública las
universidades públicas la educación
pública en general también determinadas
empresas que fueron fundadas dentro del
periodo del desarrollismo durante la
segunda mitad del siglo 20 algunas
empresas públicas siguen manteniendo
algún grado de prestigio elevado dentro
de la población costarricense según
observamos en estudios de opinión
realizado de manera persistente por la
universidad de costa rica las
instituciones políticas en el país que
sí se ven un poco más afectadas por la
percepción y por la opinión pública
costarricense son las que tienen algún
tipo carácter de representación formal
los partidos políticos son la más clara
en estudios de opinión los partidos
políticos aparecen consistentemente como
una institución peor evaluada aparecen
incluso peor evaluados que el propio
gobierno la república o que la propia
asamblea legislativa el gobierno de la
república recordemos del presidente
carlos alvarado durante estos cuatro
años ha mantenido unos índices de
popularidad
que son de los más bajos para los
mandatarios recientes desde que por
ejemplo en la universidad de costa rica
realizamos estos estudios de opinión y
salvo con contadas excepciones donde
coyunturalmente el presidente se ha
visto un poco más favorecido pero en
términos generales las instituciones
políticas que tienen algún carácter como
digo de representación formal han sido
muy golpeadas por la opinión pública y
quizás uno puede interpretar que la
elección de chávez traer detrás de sí
como causa este desprestigio que se
mantiene la sociedad costarricense
estas instancias de representación
formal quedará por ver como mencionaba
tanto manuel como larisa y la capacidad
que pueda tener el ahora presidente
electo rodrigo de chávez para
efectivamente ser un mandatario
conciliatorio que en campaña electoral
no ha demostrado serlo pero que en el
ejercicio de gobierno llegará el momento
donde tendrá que tomar la decisión de si
será un mandatario conciliatorio o si se
mantendrá dentro de la misma línea
intransigencia y de abandono el diálogo
social que hemos mantenido sobre todo
durante estos cuatro años de la
administración del presidente carlos
alvarado en medio de los extendidos
ciclos de protesta y de conflictividad
social en el país bueno ahora le
pregunto manuel también por esta
democracia tan estable y por esta
relación un poco
distante que tiene el ahora presidente
electo con las instituciones que se
puede esperar de su gobierno
en el paraíso también hay problemas de
alguna forma de la democracia cosa
residencia al ser una de las más
estables se esperaba mucho de ella hay
muchas expectativas sin embargo lo que
hemos visto recientemente por las
protestas por los problemas económicos
es que hay un caldo de cultivo para la
insatisfacción con la democracia lo que
se quiere esperar al final de cuentas de
una democracia modelo es que las
instituciones funcionen sin embargo como
mencionaba alejandro una institución
fundamental como son los partidos
políticos no están funcionando de hecho
al final de cuentas el partido
liberacionista uno de los pilares de la
democracia costarricense pues hoy ha
salido derrotado entonces eso demuestra
a final de cuentas que los
costarricenses están buscando nuevas
formas de representación sin embargo
estas formas de la presentación puede
incluso caer incluso en el autoritarismo
y eso lo que hace es pensar al final de
cuentas en qué rumbo puede caer costa
rica en digamos en su historial
democrático entonces al final de cuentas
pienso yo que lo que va a suceder
dependerá mucho de qué tan fuertes son
las instituciones democráticas en costa
rica y pienso un poco en el congreso
pienso un poco en los partidos frente a
una deriva autoritaria que ya anuncia al
final de cuentas en un presidente chávez
desde su campaña electoral bueno ahora
pasó a hablar con larisa y le preguntó
también por este caso del pago de
sobornos a cambio de obras públicas que
alcanzó hasta un asesor del presidente
carlos alvarado que tanto influyó este
esta situación en el descontento de los
votantes en esta en estos comicios
claro estamos frente a varios casos de
corrupción no sólo en de obras públicas
sino también un descontento incluso para
la figura de los alcaldes en costa del
que vemos que estamos frente al caso
diamante azteca este entonces también no
sólo con incluso con la figura del poder
ejecutivo sino también es con la figura
misma de los poderes municipales y me
parece que hay un descontento muy claro
de la población con la ejecución del
gobierno actual entonces podemos ver
incluso expresaba como y no se esperaba
que el partido acción ciudadana llegará
a desaparecer en estas elecciones llegar
a no tener ninguna representación en
asamblea legislativa se esperaba que el
resultado de este partido fuera por
abajo pero nunca se lleva a plantear que
no que no llegara a tener ninguna
representación política es la primera
vez en costa rica que vemos como un
partido que acaba de terminar este un
gobierno ejecutivo en más dos gobiernos
ejecutivos ya que el siguiente período
sin ninguna representación legislativa
entonces me parece que el electorado
mismo está expresando su voluntad y su
descontento con las instituciones
políticas incluso como nos dice manuel
vemos que podemos ser también esperar en
este gobierno que que se defina incluso
lo que es la confianza que se tiene en
las instituciones públicas desde costa
áfrica vemos que sea un proceso este de
desconfianza en las instituciones
públicas pero muy graves constante que
no fue que tuvieron un corte entonces
podemos decir bueno la cana delante se
desconfía totalmente las instituciones
públicas de género todo este desprecio
este hasta la institucionalidad
democrática sino que se va dando como un
proceso en un proceso constante en el
tiempo y que se vea alimentado por esos
procesos de corrupción entonces vemos
que también los procesos de corrupción
han tenido este gran impacto en la
ciudadanía cada vez que vemos un caso
nueva conducción vemos las encuestas
posterior a estos casos de corrupción y
vemos cómo aumenta la desconfianza y
cómo aumenta cada vez más rápido cada
vez que vemos casos más frecuentes de
corrupción la corrupción está aumentando
este la desconfianza en instituciones
mucho más pero lo que hubiera hecho en
el ciclo pasado también vemos un cambio
muy fundamental en costa rica y es que
los casos de corrupción callas son más
frecuentes y más investigados y más
mediatizados cosa que no veíamos por
ejemplo los gobiernos pasados entonces
ahora terminamos una campaña electoral
con un año anterior donde hubieron tres
casos grandes de corrupción que
implicaron instituciones de partidos
políticos municipales este también
proyectos de infraestructura entonces
vemos un amalgama este de poder
ejecutivo poder judicial este
municipalidades todas y partidos
políticos también dicho sea de paso
todas dentro de esta gran gama de casos
de corrupción también empresarios
privados entonces el país está que está
descontento y eso claramente se observa
en las elecciones vemos que por ejemplo
este 42 por ciento de abstencionismo es
el más alto que hemos tenido y es
preocupante realmente que las personas
no se vean involucradas así mismo los
también que tiene otro gran problema y
es la participación ciudadana si bien
nos decía alejandro venimos saliendo de
unos ciclos de protesta la participación
ciudadana instituciones no está siendo
real entonces eso también están logrando
afectar a sí mismo no sólo la percepción
que se tiene de las instituciones sino
también cómo lograr cambiar las
instituciones entonces pero tenemos que
tal vez esperar que el gobierno o sea o
lo que hacer un gobierno conciliatorio
como nos decía la compañera alejandro o
sino muy bien autoritario y eso traería
graves consecuencias por el país también
bueno en este momento vamos a hacer una
actualización del conteo de votos porque
a esta hora ya hay un 95 a 93 por ciento
de los votos escrutados y se mantiene la
ventaja de rodrigo de chávez con 5 en
más del 52 por ciento de los votos
mientras que josé maría figueres logra
más del 47 por ciento
y bueno otro de los temas fundamentales
en costa rica es el liderazgo y
activismo en foros climáticos y en
materia ambiental esto le permitió al
país captar millonarios fondos y también
reconocimiento su cobertura forestal es
de más del 53 por ciento de su
territorio y alcanzó un 99,98 por ciento
de generación eléctrica de fuentes
renovables le pregunto manuel de alguna
manera se pueden ver estas políticas
afectadas con la llegada de chávez o el
mandatario va a seguir con este tipo de
políticas en el país efectivamente como
todos los presidentes deben seguir una
tradición sin embargo viendo desde el
punto de vista de chávez va a ser
imposible seguir esa tradición durante
que vamos algunas ciertas reformas
debido a los recortes que el acuerdo con
el fondo monetario internacional vamos a
atraer también hay que tener en cuenta
que tanto figueres como chávez en sus
campañas se rechazaron aprobar o
ratificar el acuerdo de escazú entonces
digamos que eso también era un mensaje
ya previo desde la campaña a que
efectivamente esa tradición
ambientalista que tenía costa rica
podría cambiar pero yo siento que la
situación económica la situación que
tiene el país ahora frente a un nuevo
gobierno y un gobierno que no tiene
vamos al final de cuenta los apoyos
necesarios en el congreso seguramente va
a afectar al final de cuentas esa
política medioambiental de la cual costa
rica- digamos es digamos un ejemplo a
nivel mundial así es un pionero tanto en
la región como a nivel global y por ello
le pregunto lo mismo a alejandro de
alguna manera las políticas
ambientalistas que ha mantenido costa
rica hasta este momento podrían verse
afectadas con la llegada de chávez al
poder
quedaría por observar y por colaborar
efectivamente con el terminar haciendo
el posicionamiento final del ahora
presidente electo ya que durante campaña
electoral dio mensajes quizás un tanto
ambiguos en cuando fue cuestionado por
política ambiental en este caso el
candidato josé maría figueres si tenía
dentro de su programa de gobierno y
dentro de su discurso en general el tema
de la política ambiental como uno de los
ejes centrales de un eventual gobierno
suyo a pesar de que como menciona muy
bien manuel y no josé maría al igual que
don rodrigo se negaron y se respondieron
de manera negativa cuando se les
cuestionaba por la posibilidad de firmar
el acuerdo es casi a pesar de que es
casi desde la puesta un acuerdo firmado
en el caso una cuna
aquí de la provincia de san josé la
capital de costa rica
entonces si queda la incógnita quizás
con el posicionamiento final que vaya a
tener el presidente electo rodrigo a
chávez ya que en determinados temas si
ha mantenido una línea congruente con
esa tradición que se menciona mientras
que en otros se ha despreciado o si ha
descartado la posibilidad de profundizar
en determinadas políticas que quizás su
contendiente o josé maría figueres
promovía de manera más enérgica
entonces
quizás no sea un retroceso muy evidente
pero sí probablemente vaya a ser un
presidente que finalmente tendrá
reservas en determinados temas muy
puntuales en comparación con lo que
hubiera sido por ejemplo el candidato el
ahora perdedor josé maría figueres bueno
y ahora pasó a preguntarle a larissa que
chaves prometió mientras que estaba en
campaña que va a hacer una revisión de
una reciente flexibilización de las
restricciones a la fecundación in vitro
y al aborto sabemos que en costa rica el
aborto es legal cuando el embarazo pone
en riesgo la salud de la mujer de alguna
manera estamos viendo un retroceso
podría darse un retroceso en los
derechos para las mujeres ha habido una
importante campaña feminista para tratar
de que chávez no llegara al poder pero
hoy está como presidente electo
bueno claro sabes para empezar acá con
este punto tenemos que considerar que
para una reforma es de la fecundación in
vitro o una reforma tanto del aborto
terapéutico o una ampliación de la
restricción este estos son las formas
que pudo necesariamente pasar por
asamblea legislativa y realmente a la
poca capacidad de negociación que están
que está teniendo la campaña de rodrigo
chávez ahora electo presidente dudo
mucho que se logre hacer un retroceso en
los derechos humanos sin embargo lo que
sí podemos considerar dado su campaña
política y dado también a sus
expresiones conservadoras del partido es
que tampoco va a haber un avance en
derechos humanos bueno esto puede ser un
tema por verse sin embargo a lo que
debemos en el discurso expresado por el
partido político asimismo con la
cercanía que ha expresado el partido
político este a movimientos evangélicos
oa movimientos conservadores del país no
podemos esperar en un avance en los
derechos humanos entonces podemos estar
hablando de un estancamiento en el tema
de derechos humanos y de derechos
reproductivos de la mujer
bueno y le pregunto manuel también
porque justamente considera usted
también que podría haber un
estancamiento en los derechos humanos
con este presidente en el poder si
efectivamente lo ahora es decir un
presidente que se niega a digamos
ampliar más los progresos en materia de
los derechos sexuales y los bloqueos de
la mujer que de campaña lo dijo al final
de cuentas va a digamos detener digamos
todo ese ritmo de reforma sobre todo
pensando en que costa rica discúlpeme
que lo interrumpa porque en este momento
conectamos con la señal del primer
discurso del ahora presidente electo
rodrigo chávez
buenas noches compatriotas
[Música]
recibo con la más profunda humildad
esta decisión sagrada del pueblo
costarricense
para mí este no es un momento para
festejar
este resultado para mí no es una medalla
ni un trofeo
sino una enorme responsabilidad
colmada del resto de dificultades que
todos nosotros vamos a solucionar en
primer lugar le doy gracias infinitas a
medios y alas a todas las mujeres y
hombres costarricenses
así como a mi familia por haber acudido
a una jornada democrática que nos
enorgullece y que nos hace brillar ante
el mundo somos de las mejores
democracias del mundo
envío
[Música]
envió mi reconocimiento a don josé maría
figueres olsen y a todas las personas
que votaron por él
lo felicito
hidalguía y le pido le ruego
humildemente a don josé maría y a su
partido que trabajemos juntos para hacer
posible lo que don jose maría
[Aplausos]
para hacer posible y lo digo se lo ruego
humildemente
trabajemos juntos para hacer
posible lo que el mismo don jose maría
llamó el milagro costarricense costa
rica lo mejor está por venir
[Aplausos]
entiendo el mandato que he recibido hoy
como una obligación para ejercer mi
liderazgo como honradez con eficiencia
transparencia y austeridad
pero también con solidaridad hacia las
personas más vulnerables de nuestra
patria
asumo el sagrado compromiso de hacer un
gobierno
democrático de diálogo respetuoso de la
constitución de la ley y de los valores
costarricenses
[Aplausos]
una vez más compatriotas los
costarricenses hemos cumplido con creces
y ejemplaridad su tarea
ahora nos toca a los que hemos sido
electos cumplir con la nuestra no se
vale fallarle a costa rica no se vale
fallarle a costa rica
[Aplausos]
discutamos lo que haya que discutir no
hay problema
discutámoslo y busquemos y encontremos
soluciones de maneras conjuntas
costarricenses eso sí con la
colaboración de todos sin que nadie sabe
el hombro costa rica nos necesita a
todos ya todas unidos de la mano si
superamos nuestras diferencias con el
propósito de que costa rica triunfe el
país estará a salvo porque tendremos más
y mejores trabajos así como mejores
servicios públicos la educación para
nuestros hijos que añoramos la salud que
necesitamos y la seguridad que merece
nuestra patria
modernizaremos juntos costarricenses el
estado y generaremos juntos también las
urgentes
oportunidades para todos los que quieran
trabajar
agricultores e industriales en nuestras
mujeres jóvenes emprendedores servidores
públicos
una ciudadanía valiente no tengan duda
una ciudadanía valiente nos da mandará
justamente cada minuto lo mejor de
nosotros yo les he prometido mi mayor
esfuerzo mi sudor y mi lágrimas por
cumplir este compromiso con la patria y
espero de todos ustedes lo mismo porque
es nuestra patria
esta misma noche
guardemos las banderas partidarias
que fácilmente nos pueden dividir y nos
confrontan esta misma noche les pido
humildemente
que nos unamos todos
bajo el azul blanco y rojo de nuestro
símbolo partió
de la bandera tricolor que nos
enorgullece
azul blanco y rojo
esa es la única bandera que tiene que
ondear
esta noche en costa rica
apartemos las mezquindades y vanidades
esta misma noche
empezaremos juntos a servir a nuestra
patria
empecemos ya
[Música]
[Aplausos]
con ese espíritu
de guardar las banderas de que nos
unamos bajo el bellísimo azul blanco y
rojo y que empecemos a servir juntos con
ese espíritu es con el que me comprometo
a gobernar
la democracia es nuestro valor punto
número uno a pesar de los inmensos retos
que tenemos no hay espacio para el
resentimiento menos para los
revanchismos o las confrontaciones
estériles
comprendo que en una campaña electoral
se dicen muchas cosas
todo cambio crea incertidumbre en muchos
casos amenace privilegios y afecte
intereses pero yo me he comprometido y
me empeñaré en impulsar profundos y
positivos cambios en la forma de
gobernar costa rica-
democráticamente la
[Aplausos]
la dura campaña que hoy finalizamos
lamentablemente convirtió al
abstencionismo en el partido político
más grande de costa rica
esta es una triste realidad que debemos
comprender y aceptar
esto no significa bajo ningún punto de
vista que los compatriotas que no
acudieron a las urnas no amen a costa
rica ni a su democracia ellos son
probablemente los más críticos y
preocupados por el futuro del país que
quisieron sacudir la conciencia de la
clase gobernante
en un ejercicio de auténtica democracia
acepto esa advertencia
como un compromiso para trabajar con más
fuerza y patriotismo por costa rica por
construir nuevos consensos con la
humildad de unos y la generosidad de
otros saben que haremos lo imposible por
devolverles la confianza
de que en costa rica el pueblo es el que
manda
[Aplausos]
hace mucho tiempo entendí que en
democracia la ley es el lenguaje y el
espíritu del estado también comprendo
que en costa rica las transformaciones
políticas
sólo son posibles mediante consensos
democráticos
el costarricense lleva en sus genes y
gracias a dios en su destino la
convicción de que los males de la
democracia sólo se corrigen con más
democracia
sólo se corrige con más democracia y
nunca
aceptaremos ni aceptarán ustedes la
imposición y la arbitrariedad
de quienquiera que sea que esté
gobernando
incluyéndome a mí
nunca aceptaremos
imposición y arbitrariedad y yo soy
parte de hoy más que nunca me
enorgullezco de que un costarricense su
más humilde servidor de raíces muy
humildes reciba el mandato de un pueblo
para dirigir una buena parte del destino
de esta noble patria
la última conversación con mi madre
días dos días antes de morir
toma hoy una relevancia aún más
importante en mi corazón en mi alma y en
mi resolución de trabajar por este país
ese día mi adorada nuestra adorada doña
alicia
me dio su bendición cuando le dije que
quería servir a mi patria mamita
esta noche
espero le ruego que me la vuelva a dar
porque los retos y dificultades que nos
esperan son muchos y de gran magnitud en
el mundo en nuestro continente y en
nuestro propio país
viéndolos a los ojos les puedo decir
venimos a servir y no a servirnos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
que dios bendiga los hogares
y a cada uno de los costarricenses
especialmente a los que hoy viven en
situación de pobreza
y de limitaciones muy serias que dios
bendiga a costa rica y de mi parte les
digo muchas gracias muchas gracias
muchas gracias desde lo más profundo de
mi corazón que dios bendiga a nuestra
patria dorada estamos para servir
seguimos para adelante
costa rica lo mejor está por venir que
dios los bendiga que el día nos bendiga
vamos para adelante
muchas gracias
gracias
[Aplausos]
bueno pues vimos a un rodrigo chávez
conmovido en principio pausado y luego
bastante acelerado bastante feliz en
esta victoria que logra y antes de
continuar analizando su discurso vamos a
ver las palabras de felicitación que le
envió el presidente carlos alvarado a
través de twitter aseguró que lo llamó
para expresarle su felicitación
efectuar una transición ordenada y
externarles sus mejores deseos en las
tareas que enfrentará como presidente
número 49 de costa rica
felicidades costa rica por una nueva
jornada democrática este fue el mensaje
del actual presidente carlos alvarado
ahora volvemos a hablar un poco de estas
primeras palabras de este primer
discurso en el que habló mucho de
responsabilidad y de la obligación que
él considera que tiene de actuar dijo
que recibe con humildad la decisión del
pueblo habla de que es un momento de
asumir esta responsabilidad que
significa llegar a la presidencia
agradeció a sus simpatizantes por votar
resaltó a costa rica como un eje de la
democracia en el mundo envía un saludo a
figueres y a sus votantes y le pidió al
ex presidente que trabajen juntos por un
país mejor aseguró que ejercerá su
mandato con honradez transparencia y
humildad y dijo que hará un gobierno de
diálogo respetuoso de la constitución la
ley y los valores costarricenses y se
comprometió a no fallarle a costa rica
hasta ahora conectamos con cindy regidor
desde san jose de sindh y qué más
podemos resaltar de este primer
pronunciamiento de chávez como
presidente electo
bueno yo lo que veo como bien decías es
pues un candidato que ahora pues se
siente muy feliz de haber logrado este
triunfo que pues creo que realmente fue
sorpresivo realmente en lo que se
comentaba tanto en liberación nacional
como en progreso social democrático es
que los números inicialmente estaban
bastante cerrados y así lo decían las
encuestas y finalmente pues chávez se
alzó con la victoria y destacó que hay
un tono más conciliador muy distinto al
de la campaña que estuvo llena de
ataques entre ambos contrincantes fue
una campaña bastante agotadora porque
mucha gente en lo que vio en los debates
no fueron propuestas sino más bien
cuáles eran los aspectos negativos de
los dos candidatos y ahora vemos que don
rodrigo chávez pues prefiere enfocarse
en cómo deben trabajar juntos él y sus
adversarios políticos para lograr sacar
adelante a costa rica destacó también
que mencionó de manera reiterada el
respeto hacia la democracia a él se le
criticó fuertemente por presentar
opciones el poco para mandar en su
gobierno como por ejemplo utilizar el
referendo para tomar distintas acciones
que otros gobiernos no han logrado pasar
en el pasado y pues también había tenido
encontronazos ataques directos hacia la
prensa hacia medios de comunicación
tradicionales locales y ahora vemos eso
un tono mucho más conciliador habrá que
ver si eso se mantiene a lo largo de su
presidencia
en la elección pasada vimos como también
el actual presidente carlos alvarado
hizo también un llamado a que trabajaran
todos los sectores todos los partidos
políticos en conjunto para lograr sacar
adelante el país eso ocurrió en los
primeros meses pero poco a poco eso se
fue desmoronando veremos cómo le va al
presidente electo rodrigo chávez que
tiene una asamblea legislativa en la que
solamente tiene diez diputados de 57 y
entonces tiene que tener una gran
capacidad negociadora para precisamente
poder gobernar junto con esa asamblea
legislativa que ésta es bastante
fraccionada cindy el tribuno el supremo
de elecciones va a entregar el
escrutinio definitivo el martes ya hoy
estamos hablando hasta este momento de
un porcentaje escrutado del 96 66 por 63
por ciento cambia en algo este resultado
queda por vencedor a chávez
yo diría que definitivamente este es el
resultado más de un millón de votos el
candidato bueno ahora presidente electo
logró triplicar la cantidad de votos que
logró en la primera ronda el 6 de
febrero y pues a lo mejor variará un
poco el tema del abstencionismo el
porcentaje a lo mejor aumentará un poco
el porcentaje de don rodrigo chávez pero
el tribunal supremo electoral de costa
rica- es considerado como uno de los más
sólidos los más respetados y
prestigiosos del continente y del mundo
y hay una confianza absoluta de que los
resultados entregados y dados a conocer
hoy son los resultados que son los
verdaderos que no hay ningún tipo de
diferencias con lo que encontrarán a
partir del martes 5 de abril cuando haya
el escrutinio final de cada uno de los
votos emitidos por los costarricenses en
esta jornada sin día ustedes muchas
gracias por esta ampliación por favor le
pido que permanezca conectada con
nosotros y vuelvo con manuel que tuve
que interrumpir lo cuando he estado
hablando justamente de derechos humanos
y de si se ven avances a la vista
durante la presidencia de chávez no lo
decía creo que haber un estancamiento el
presidente chávez fue muy claro digamos
en su campaña electoral que no iba a
aumentar el ritmo de las reformas en
derechos sexuales y reproductivos de la
mujer e incluso digamos el panorama no
era muy favorable para este tema sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que su contendor
figueres tampoco apoyaba digamos la
opción del aborto entonces también es un
poco paradójico incluso que costa rica
teniendo la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos y que ha hecho
pronunciamientos en ese sentido de
alguna forma el país que la alberga de
alguna forma se resiste a esos cambios
entonces seguramente lo que vamos a
tener es un estancamiento no un
retroceso pero sí un estancamiento muy
profundo en este tema de los derechos
reproductivos y sexuales de la mujer
bueno ahora paso a hablar con alejandro
y le pregunto cómo se movieron las
alianzas y el electorado para este
balotaje que termina con la victoria de
chávez si en la primera vuelta fue el
que resultó segundo en la intención de
voto
si de cara a esta segunda ronda la
mayoría de partidos políticos si
tuvieron una determinada reserva antes
de pactar algún tipo de alianza o
ofrecer su adhesión a alguno de los dos
candidatos que estaban disputando esta
segunda ronda
quizás podemos dar el caso del partido
progreso social democrático con el ahora
presidente electo rodrigo de chávez
únicamente recibió la adhesión de un
partido político y fue un partido
político que no quedó en los primeros
lugares de la votación es sabemos que la
votación presidencial en primera ronda
estuvo concentrada en seis partidos
políticos principalmente de 25 que
estaban en la contienda y la única
adhesión que recibió al partido progreso
social democrático como digo vino de un
partido que no estaba dentro de estos
principales seis partidos que disputaron
en la primera ronda presidencial el caso
del partido liberación nacional
y su candidato josé maría figueres
pasa un fenómeno prácticamente muy
similar la diferencia de que el
candidato josé maría figueres y recibió
la adhesión de una cantidad un poco
mayor de ex candidatos presidenciales a
pesar de que como de como digo todos
estos ex candidatos presidenciales se
encontraron fuera de los seis partidos
que sí concentraron la mayor cantidad
del voto en primera ronda
quedará por estudiar ya mediante
estudios de opinión posteriores a esta
segunda ronda con más detalle cuál fue
el traslado de votos según el partido en
primera ronda a esta segunda ronda sin
embargo si pareciera ser que el partido
liberación nacional se encontró con
mayores dificultades para ampliar su
caudal electoral de primera ronda a
pesar de que bueno en una segunda ronda
si suele haber en términos absolutos
un momento para ambas opciones sin
embargo si fue bastante insuficiente el
apoyo de o de partidarios de otras
agrupaciones
tal cual lo revelan los los resultados
finales que estamos obteniendo y por el
contrario pareciera ser que si el don
rodrigo fue más efectivo para movilizar
votantes de otros partidos en primera
ronda bueno ya lo decías cindy es que en
este primer pronunciamiento vimos a un
chávez mucho más conciliador hablando y
hablando un poco más de respeto hacia la
democracia que era una de las
principales críticas que se le había
hecho en campaña él había dicho que de
ser necesario pasaría por encima del
congreso y de otras instituciones
democráticas para resolver cuestiones
políticas importantes incluso habló de
referendos que le espera a la democracia
costarricense con la llegada de chávez
al poder
si efectivamente
dentro de su discurso de campaña el
ahora presidente electo rodrigo de
chávez
planteó la posibilidad de solventar vía
referéndum aquellos proyectos de ley que
él considera neurálgicos para su futuro
gobierno en caso de que no fructificaran
en la asamblea legislativa tal cual
hemos estado mencionando a lo largo de
todo este especial don rodrigo chávez y
el partido progreso social democrático
únicamente contarán con díaz diputados
de 57 muy lejos por ejemplo los 19
diputados que contaría el partido
liberación nacional que es la fracción
más numerosa en la asamblea legislativa
se ha comentado y se ha analizado por
especialistas en el derecho de nuestro
país que la propuesta de don rodrigo era
el de solventar vía referéndum aquellos
y aquellas iniciativas que no prosperen
en la asamblea legislativa pues sí
tienen determinados límites establecidos
por la constitución un tema en el cual
don rodrigo ha sido muy enfático en que
desearía eventualmente convocar un
referéndum es en lo que costaría que
llamamos las pensiones de lujo que
básicamente es aquellas pensiones que
reciben determinados altos jerarcas
dentro del sector público que si son
considerados y que chad y que arrastran
una gran impopularidad la porque en la
población costarricense entonces don
rodrigo de chávez ha prometido solventar
vía referéndum este tema sin embargo
constitucionalmente las pensiones son un
tema que expresamente quedan excluidos
de la posibilidad de realizar cualquier
tipo de referéndum junto con materia
presupuestaria materia tributaria
y
determinados actos de naturaleza
administrativa
entonces en dado caso de que don rodrigo
chávez pues quiera insistir en su en su
post en su propuesta de llevar vía
referéndum pues allí será sometido a
prueba los pesos y contrapesos que
tradicionalmente llamamos de una
democracia como la costarricense si hay
que hacer la salvedad de que él no dice
abiertamente que va a realizar un
referéndum sobre pensiones sino que va a
realizar un referéndum sobre la
posibilidad de que la sala
constitucional nuestro tribunal
constitucional
tenga la posibilidad de interpretar
la misma carta magna y sobre este tema
que como mencionó el tema de las
pensiones de lujo de las así llamadas
pensiones de lujo ha sido un tema
sumamente impopular en los últimos años
y bueno don rodrigo pues ha acumulado
ganado determinado
votante que si considera que esta es una
iniciativa en la cual un eventual
gobierno debería avanzar sin embargo
como mencionó una iniciativa de este
tipo por mencionar a una de las de las
muchas que se pueden mencionar pondrán a
prueba el sistema de pesos y contrapesos
la relación con los medios de
comunicación tradicionales también es
otro aspecto en el cual la democracia
costarricense se verá pues sometida a
prueba entonces sí serán años quizás de
conflictividad y de
desencuentros del gobierno de la
república como estas otras instituciones
que son pilares de un régimen
democrático como el costarricense larisa
le hago la misma pregunta que le espera
a la democracia con un mandatario que
habla de pasar por encima del congreso y
de otras instituciones en el país
claro en un primer momento en campaña se
refirió a esto a pasar por encima a
realizar referéndum como una forma de
gobernanza sin embargo creo que ahorita
estamos viendo un detalle importante y
es que el discurso presidencial está
mostrando un cambio entre entre el
presidente en campaña y el presidente
ahora electo vemos un discurso más
conciliador un discurso que busca
alianzas que incluso pide este en cierta
manera una negociación con el partido
que quedó en segundo lugar con el prn
que también es el partido con la bancada
más grande dentro de la asamblea
legislativa entonces estamos viendo que
tal vez podemos estar frente a un cambio
de verdad de candidato en campaña pero
sus candidatos ya electo un candidato
que ya electo eres consciente de los
días cosas consciente tal vez de lo que
implica la negociación y la realización
de acuerdos para lograr generar
gobernanza dentro del sistema
legislativo así como existe un ejecutivo
entonces podemos ver ese incluso como
nos decía alejandro y una gran ventaja
de costa rica es que tenemos este gran
sistema de pesos y contrapesos y una
institucionalidad muy sólida
su división de poderes que está frente
al rodríguez chávez entonces quien si en
un determinado momento el presidente
propusiera verdad realizar estos
acuerdos de realizar por ejemplo
referendos pasar por encima a la
institucionalidad pues después tenemos
una institucionalidad bastante fuerte
hasta el momento entonces podemos tener
verdad un sistema de contrapesos que nos
puede proteger a los ciudadanos sin
embargo también los sistemas y la
institucionalidad democracia democrática
siempre sabemos que está en riesgo
entonces no podemos asumir la como hecha
o no podemos asumir la verdad como
estable sin embargo podemos defenderla y
podemos también tenerla por lo menos
tenemos los mecanismos para una correcta
defensa ante ante cualquier propuesta
que pueda ir en esta rama autoritaria
pueda ir en esta mano populista bueno ya
hablamos ya se nos está terminando el
tiempo pero ahora hablamos en materia
internacional manuel que significa el
triunfo de chávez en la región porque
pese a un momento complejo costa rica
sigue siendo vista como una de las
naciones más estables contrario su
vecino nicaragua vemos un poco más
arriba a honduras al salvador ya
guatemala
bueno lo que tenemos en costa rica es
primero un giro hacia la derecha
en este sentido digamos pasamos del
gobierno del partido de acción ciudadana
de izquierda a uno que es un nuevo
partido que es en este caso el partido
de chávez que es de derecha también
vemos que en el plano centroamericano
tenemos que la democracia se vigoriza
mucho en la región dado que costa rica
como un modelo democrático digamos se
sostiene digamos los estándares
democráticos sobre todo en una región
donde como tú hubieras dicho nicaragua
digamos el caso del salvador ahora pues
ha tenido muchos problemas de déficit
democráticos y finalmente creo yo que
también esto demuestra que en la región
el voto castigo ha sido una constante en
este súper ciclo electoral es decir
todos los presidentes independientemente
de su filiación ideológica es decir de
izquierda a derecha han perdido el poder
frente a sus opositores entonces digamos
que esto también se refleja mucho en la
tendencia que hoy nos presenta gusta
rica en las elecciones bueno justamente
en este contexto vuelvo a conectar con
nuestra corresponsal y cindy regidores
cindy que reacciones se han producido
alrededor de estos comicios en la zona y
haya algún pronunciamiento y también qué
importancia tiene para la región que
chávez el ganador de estas elecciones
bueno en redes sociales vemos como
nicaragüense salvadoreño guatemaltecos
seguían de cerca la elección y están
bastante sorprendidos por el
abstencionismo que fue tan alto y que
finalmente pues terminó dando como
resultado también la victoria de rodrigo
chávez hay también preocupación por los
señalamientos que ya se han hecho y
bueno el candidato y ahora presidente
electo dijo en su momento que él quería
tener relaciones cordiales con daniel
ortega el presidente de nicaragua de un
régimen autoritario eso causó cierta
preocupación sobre todo porque costa
rica pues se ha posicionado como un país
defensor de los derechos humanos y de la
democracia a los diferentes espacios
multilaterales y no en balde es parte de
una alianza recién formada con república
dominicana y panamá llamada alianza para
el fortalecimiento de la
institucionalidad democrática y eso es
una manera de poder incidir en la región
en estos temas entonces habrá que ver
pues qué tipo de gobierno hará el don
rodrigo chávez y cuál será también ahora
su estrategia en la diplomacia
internacional si continuará abogando por
estos temas y principalmente en casos
como el del vecino
bueno pues le hago esta misma pregunta
como les decía se nos va acabando el
tiempo en este especial sobre las
elecciones en costa rica que dan la
victoria a rodrigo chávez como el nuevo
ocupante del palacio presidencial
larissa qué significa esta victoria para
la región
claro un punto importante acá que
podemos analizar es cuál ha sido también
la imagen internacional de rodrigo
chávez vemos que por ejemplo los
artículos carburo y caber washington
post en new york times' han afectado a
la imagen internacional que se tiene
rodrigo chávez esto también para la
región puede significar en las
relaciones internacionales una
afectación tenemos que ver cómo se va a
desempeñar el candidato y a quién va a
colocar en la cancillería porque un
punto muy importante desde partido
político es que como se ha desempeñado
con un partido atrapar a todo no ha
tenido una estructura interna este con
fuerza entonces no tenga una estructura
interna es cuantiosa no tenga una
estructura interna sólida entonces esto
nos presenta un gran problema y es que
la falta de equipo al no saber nosotros
tiene más en la falta de equipo habrá
que ver este cuál será la personalidad o
la caracterización de una persona que
vaya a poner en la cancillería que es un
punto muy importante y es que el
presidente logra escoger quién está a
cargo de la cancillería y está el
encargado el canciller es el que
relaciona toda la estructura este de la
política internacional entonces eso es
uno de los de los puntos que habrá que
ver cómo se desenvuelve en los próximos
meses ya lo mencionado en larisa y ahora
le digo alejandro porque pues sabemos
todo lo que ha ocurrido con el banco
mundial y toda esta polémica conchado es
el contradice que le hayan prohibido
entrar a las oficinas y de hecho dice
que como presidente seguirá haciendo
negocios con el banco que tiene 2.300
millones de dólares en préstamos
pendientes en costa rica como se ve en
la región su victoria
si a nivel internacional sobre todo en
medios de prensa de prestigio a nivel
internacional se ha criticado
eventualmente la posibilidad de que
costa rica eligiera como presidente a un
candidato con los antecedentes muy
claros de acoso sexual que hemos estado
comentando a lo largo de este especial
si sería
representaría a partir del día de hoy un
mensaje quizás un tanto contradictorio
para el mundo el hecho de que costa rica
efectivamente sea vista como una
democracia estable que lo sigue siendo y
que sigue siendo para muchos países de
nuestra región una democracia ejemplar
sin embargo la elección de un candidato
de este tipo pues sí da este tipo de
mensaje contradictoria alejandro le
agradezco esta intervención y a nuestros
invitados manuel gonzález aquí que nos
acompañó en el estudio alejandro molina
al arish álvarez ya nuestra corresponsal
cindy regidor les recordamos que nos
despedimos con un 96 95 por ciento de
los votos escrutados en un conteo
realmente veloz en el h rodrigo chávez
logra un 52 86 por ciento de los votos
con algo más de 1 millón 9 mil 843
sufragios mientras que josé maría
figueres que ya aceptó la derrota logró
un 47 14 por ciento de los apoyos con
más de 900 mil a ustedes les agradecemos
su sintonía y les pedimos que continúen
con nosotros que hay más información
aquí en france 24